il progresso non è più quello di una
volta
evoluzione ha visto tante volte questa
immagine anche voi fa parte del nostro
immaginario collettivo l'avete lista sul
web sui giornali e questa idea che
l'evoluzione sia stata una grande corsa
verso lo so lo zero o forse homo sapiens
di solito rappresentato come un bel
maschio bianco occidentale noi siamo
molto affezionati a questa grande
narrazione del progresso la migliore
interpretazione che io conosca è quella
dei disegnatori dei simpson che
naturalmente ci raccontano di un
evoluzione che ha portato
inevitabilmente verso homer sapien con
quella dimensione del cervello non
particolarmente rassicuranti però c'è
dietro qualcosa di profondo da in questa
immagine a un grande evoluzionista che è
scomparso dieci anni fa steve j gul
diceva che questa è la nostra più grande
e iconografia della speranza ci piace un
sacco questa immagine perché se le cose
fossero andate davvero in questo modo
noi saremmo l'apice di tutta questa
storia il suo frutto inevitabile è una
grande narrazione molto rassicurante
nella sua semplicità è l'unico modo di
raccontare l'evoluzione no naturalmente
anche se ci piace molto
un ragazzo non ancora trentenne nella
prima metà dell'ottocento l'aveva
raccontata così in un modo molto diverso
stiamo parlando di charles darwin che
appena tornato dal suo appassionante
viaggio dei cinque anni attorno al mondo
si mette a scrivere dei taccuini segreti
e
a 27 anni quindi a chi adesso sta
facendo l'università cioè a 20 quelle
tali sbrigatevi perché le rivoluzioni
scientifiche si fanno prima dei 30 anni
in un piccola piccola paginetta come
questa scrive io penso che cosa sta
pensando ai film che sta pensando a un
albero non ha una scala del progresso
quindi sta pensando al fatto che
l'evoluzione è una storia di diversità è
una storia di ramificazioni è una storia
plurale è una storia che si alimenta
della diversità individuale ea sua volta
produce diversità quindi la biodiversità
è il combustibile e anche l'esito
dell'evoluzione noi abbiamo approfondito
molto questa idea di darwin un secolo e
mezzo dopo
abbiamo scoperto che non solo aveva
ragione ma che forse questo non è
nemmeno un albero ma è ancora qualcosa
di più irregolare una sorta di cespuglio
della biodiversità e noi siamo dentro
questa storia
guardate questa immagine questo è
l'albero della vita
darwin avrebbe voluto tanto vedere
questa immagine è stata ricostruita poco
tempo fa e dell tree of life universale
quello che include tutte le forme di
vita
oggi presenti sulla terra al meno
conosciute e classificate
guardatela un po e due terzi della vita
è fatta di organismi con una sola
cellula
quindi hai voglia a dire che
l'evoluzione procede verso la
complessità o la grande quantità di
cellule in realtà per due terzi è fatta
gli organismi con una sola cella e voi
siete li siete un piccolo voi
naturalmente io mi escludo da questo
computo per il momento voi siete un
piccolissimo ramoscello 7 rami dovete
fare dentro quel piccolo ramoscello
degli animali tra l'altro abbastanza
vicino ai funghi non so se questa cosa
vi piace o meno e alle piante
naturalmente e poi tutti gli organismi
fatti con cellule con il dna conservato
nel nucleo quindi vedete quanto è stata
straordinaria questa storia di diversità
e noi siamo alla periferia dell'impero
della biodiversità
ma se fate uno zoom e guardate dentro la
nostra storia particolare quella che è
avvenuta da quando ci siamo separati
dall'antenato comune con le scimpanzé
fino a oggi quindi una storia di sei
milioni di anni che sembra tanto ma
nell'evoluzione poi non è così tanto
guardate che cespuglio di forme trovate
dentro questa avventura umana più di 20
specie di ominidi noi siamo una di
queste e cos'è homo sapiens è l'ultimo
ramoscello vedete la in alto di una
storia di diversità
pensate che una scoperta quasi
incredibile che abbiamo fatto due tre
anni fa è molto recente sulla terra fino
a poche migliaia di anni fa esistevano
almeno 45 forse forme umane
contemporaneamente quindi siamo da soli
sulla terra da pochissimo tempo una
storia di diversità di imprevedibilità
di contingenza ed è così ricca questa
storia evolutiva perché noi abbiamo
sempre vissuto in un contesto instabile
è l'instabilità ecologica che ha fatto
la nostra fortuna che ha fatto questa
diversità e noi siamo qui perché siamo
flessibili sappiamo capacità di
modificare i nostri comportamenti a far
per far fronte a questa instabilità
ecologica allora quello che vi ho appena
fatto vedere fino adesso è un po uno
shock no naturalmente perché siamo la
periferia dell'impero non siamo più al
centro della biodiversità non siamo più
l'apice di un progresso vecchia maniera
adesso in pochi minuti vorrei però far
vedere che in realtà non dobbiamo
disperarci proprio del tutto questa
questo messaggio della contingenza della
nostra storia potrebbe in realtà essere
una grande occasione allora partiamo da
questo shock e proviamo a vedere insieme
tre spunti che la natura ci suggerisce a
proposito della creatività il primo a
questo naturalmente la biodiversità è il
nostro progresso del titolo di questa
giornata dal mio punto di vista vale
letteralmente
nel senso che la biodiversità si può
intendere in vari modi la bio di vista
delle specie naturalmente che abitano
negli ecosistemi che li popolano anche
di trasformano ma quello che noi vediamo
recentemente è che la biodiversità forse
è un concetto più ampio
qualcuno parla oggi ha pubblicato un
paper due anni fa abbiamo parlato di
diversità bio culturale perché perché
molte ricerche scientifiche ci fanno
vedere questa cosa se vuoi mappate la
diversità nel mondo vi accorgete che
dove c'è il massimo di diversità
ecologica il massimo di diversità delle
specie biologiche
c'è anche il massimo della diversità
culturale e linguistica dove c'è
diversità biologica c'è anche diversità
culturale e viceversa gli hot spot sono
quasi sempre gli stessi
e voglio ricordare che l'italia
nonostante tutto quello che abbiamo
combinato fino adesso resta un grande
hot spot di biodiversità sia quella
naturale classica che quella linguistica
culturale perché siamo una terra di
passaggio una terra di confronti di
sovrapposizioni continue facciamone
tesoro perché è davvero il petrolio del
nostro futuro questa diversità è un
esempio abbastanza impressionante
prendete soltanto un isola continente
come la nuova guinea in nuova guinea
fino al quindicesimo secolo si parlavano
tante lingue più di 5.000 quante oggi se
ne parlano in tutto il resto del mondo
e ancora adesso solo lì se ne pagano più
di 700 perché perché c'è isolamento cioè
diversità c'è irregolarità dell'ambiente
e questo produce diversità culturale ma
anche diversità linguistica e diversità
di specie quindi forse il primo
messaggio che l'evoluzione ci lascia a
proposito di progresso è se vuoi
progredire aumenta il numero delle
possibilità non ridurli secondo
messaggio anche questo è abbastanza
semplice è riecheggiato già in molti
interventi
noi dobbiamo adattarci all'ambiente ma
noi esseri umani in particolare
trasformiamo l'ambiente e la nicchia
ecologica umana non è più soltanto una
nicchia naturale in senso classico ma
una nicchia piena di strumenti piena di
oggetti
piena di simboli è una nicchia bio
culturale e quello che hanno imparato
gli evoluzionisti oggi è questo modello
che si chiama costruzione di nicchie
vuol dire una cosa semplice vuol dire
che noi trasformiamo l'ambiente al quale
poi dobbiamo adattarci quindi ci
adattiamo sopravviviamo questo ambiente
ma siamo anche i costruttori di questa
nicchia ecologica e il fatto bello ma
anche inquietante è che gli
evoluzionisti sanno che quando si
instaura una dinamica di questo tipo che
è biunivoca no è di tipo costruttivo
il sistema evolve in modo molto rapido e
tendenzialmente fuori controllo quindi
in modo imprevedibile noi cambiamo
l'ambiente che cambia noi e questo
accelera tantissimo il processo
e i nostri figli si ritroveranno nativi
di un ambiente che noi abbiamo
trasformato e loro lo trasformeranno e
quell ambiente trasformerà la
generazione successiva e quindi è un
processo ricorsivo da un po di tempo a
questa parte prima non era così prima
era più semplice dovevamo noi rincorrere
un po l'ambiente adesso lo trasformiamo
ma non illudiamoci di essere tirati
fuori dobbiamo comunque riuscire a
sopravvivere un ambiente che cambiamo
noi il terzo messaggio è che
nell'evoluzione non si butta via niente
nel senso che nell'evoluzione tutto può
tornare utile in termini di ri utilizzi
e riuso abbiamo imparato questo schema
da tantissime ricerche scientifiche
oggi questi sono tutti esempi di animali
che hanno imparato a sopravvivere
riutilizzando in un modo creativo un po
opportunista ma molto molto ingegnoso
strutture che avevano sviluppato per
tutt'altri ragioni e quindi il bello
dell'evoluzione anche questo no tu
sviluppi una competenza un comportamento
in un dato ambiente per una certa
ragione e poi lo riutilizzi con una
sorta di bricolage
naturalmente non tutte queste specie
sono oggi ancora viventi a quella in
alto litio sauro e si è estinto ma non
preoccupatevi di questo nel senso che a
lungo termine nell'evoluzione tutte le
specie sono estinte per riecheggiare una
vecchia battuta noi diamo
200.000 anni homo sapiens mediamente una
specie come la nostra sopravvive alcune
milioni di anni quindi tranquilli noi
siamo molto giovani
siamo una specie bambina ma stiamo
accelerando molto questo processo quindi
dovremmo guardare con attenzione a
quello che che stiamo facendo
vi lascio soltanto con due esempi perché
si parla molto di complessità in questa
giornata è di solito alla domanda che
cos'è il sistema che ti da l'idea di
maggiore complessità noi pensiamo alle
stelle all'universo pensiamo una giungla
rigogliosa
in realtà sul piano quantitativo i due
sistemi naturali biologici più complessi
che conosciamo sono dentro di noi non
fuori di noi sono il nostro genoma e il
nostro cervello sono sistemi di una
complessità biologica strepitosa
incredibile frutto di continui
rimaneggiamenti niente di ottimale però
qualcosa di che ha straordinarie
potenzialità e allora guardate questo è
un signore giovanissimo a capo di
migliaia di ricercatori a cambridge si
chiama progetto è in coda e stanno
mappando tutto il genoma non soltanto
quello dei geni ma anche il modo con cui
geni si regolano si esprimono e danno
come risultato il fenotipo cioè come
appariamo noi
esternamente una volta si parlava di dna
spazzatura guardate lui dice dovremmo
parlare del futuro di jungle viene cioè
della giungla dna perché è una foresta
fitta una muraglia di elementi e non sei
mai sicuro di dove sei
ed è abbastanza facile sentirsi perduti
dentro questa giungla ciò che ci
influenza che interagisce con l'ambiente
che abbiamo dentro il nucleo di ciascuna
delle nostre cellule
è una giungla genomica e quindi la
complessità è dentro di noi
poi all'ora se le cose stanno così e io
analizzo questo sistema così complesso
mi accorgo di un altro fatto che non so
se piace tanto agli ingegneri o meno
cioè questi sistemi così creativi
così complessi non sono ottimali dal
punto di vista ingegneristico sono piene
di cose che apparentemente non servono a
niente apparentemente nel senso che non
lo sappiamo magari interagiscono entrano
in relazione allora un mio amico
genetista proposto due anni fa il test
della cipolla che è un test di realtà
molto semplice che è rivolto a coloro
che pensano che in natura tutto serva a
qualcosa e che qualsiasi base
nucleotidica nel genoma umano abbia una
funzione e lui dice che vi chiedetevi
come mai una cipolla a un genoma che è
cinque volte più grande del nostro a 5
volte il numero di geni e di basi
nucleotidiche rispetto alla nostra ora
con tutto il rispetto per la cipolla
naturalmente che è una specie di tosi
stima però dubito che voi stiate
pensando che la cipolla sia molto più
complessa di un essere umano e quindi
questo test in modo molto semplice
dimostra che per essere complessi non
bisogna avere tanti geni ma quello che
conta è come sono in relazione gli uni
con gli altri e questo è quello che
abbiamo imparato nei sistemi biologici
non conta avere tanti nodi della rete
quello che conta è che la rete sia molto
interconnessa e sia flessibile creativa
e sia capace di riconfigurarsi in un
modo flessibile quindi va bene che la
cipolla abbia così tanti geni e noi
molti di meno e l'altro grande sistema
complesso che abbiamo tutti dentro la
nostra testa e che è sfida l'universo là
fuori in termini di complessità e kant
stesso non l'aveva detto e stato citato
prima mi interrogo su l'universo là
fuori sulle stelle e poi su come si
sviluppa il senso morale dentro la mia
testa e allora un grande scienziato del
passato che è morto l'anno scorso un
premio nobel per la biologia france a
jacob vedete diceva se io guardo il
cervello e vedo come riconfigurato come
sub ottimale come la neocorteccia
interagisce con le altre forme becco le
altre partite mi accorgo che è questo
processo evolutivo assomiglia molto al
bricolage e dobbiamo moltissimo della
nostra fortuna e della creatività del
nostro cervello
al fatto che è stato capace di
riconfigurarsi più e più volte e molte
strutture del nostro cervello sono state
capaci di nascere per una certa funzione
per esempio motoria e poi sono state
riutilizzate per funzioni legati al
linguaggio per esempio ea competenze
molto più complesse quindi il bricolage
probabilmente è quello che ci c'è la
biologia uno dei segreti della
creatività biologica quindi vedrete che
si può pensare di nuovo a una qualche
forma di progresso ma non è certamente
un progresso lineare ed è un progresso
che dipende dagli effetti delle nostre
azioni
oggi grazie